irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport cette émission est réalisée
avec le concours de louis carles et
joseph petit andy perrier montage
yvonne ces restes sont christian
lemarchand illustration sonore bernard
de ronceray quatre hommes de jim un
chien un désert le hoggar une idée
allait faire des relevés le fresque
préhistorique que l'on croit exister
dans certaines grottes et pour ce faire
traverser le regard
la piste presque absente
non
bon
accident ou plutôt incidents très
fréquent inévitable une heure perdue
le chien est bien le meilleur ami de
l'homme dans les bons et les mauvais
moments
cette toile métallique donneras prise
aux pneus une jeep et dans l'autre grâce
à un treuil de nombreux efforts
une bonne suée
e
et voilà on est sauvé
ils ont eu le droit de partir mais il
leur a fallu promettre de faire
plusieurs appels radio chaque jour au
poste militaire le plus proche de
l'endroit où il se trouvait on ne sait
jamais avec le disais il vous joue des
tours se transforme enfin dans le désert
il paraît qu'on peut se perdre
tout va bien
où
la piste n'existe plus et c'est qu'un
gars qu'ils vont terminer le parcours
la jeep se révèle vraiment est la
meilleure alliée dans ces circonstances
rassurez vous il ne se transforme pas
sous l'effet de la chaleur en sorcier
mais l'un de nos quatre amis a pour
mission de faire des observations sur
l'humidité du sol la vitesse du vent
je
et la température sous abri
diable serions nous victimes d'un mirage
ici vie d'un homme romantique qu'il en
existe encore jeune beau probablement
déçu par la vie expatriés volontaires
ils ne voient jamais ou presque jamais
personne officiers méharistes il vit
entouré de quelques hommes et de ces
bêtes seul avec le silence seules avec
ses souvenirs
un sage ou un désespéré de toute façon
un homme qui a compris que les tâches
les plus obscurs les plus ignorées
n'étaient pas forcément les plus vaine
souhaitons lui la paix du coeur
l'eau est rare et précieuse sans elle
c'est la mort aussi faut-il la
transporter avec soin on le fait dans
une peau de chèvre une fois tuer la bête
et dépouillée on lui coupe les pattes on
recourt la peau est ainsi cette peau
devient une autre parfaitement étanche
m
nos quatre voyageurs arrivent le
méharistes s'en va simple coïncidence
non du dédain s'attache l'appel ailleurs
dans un endroit aussi désolé aussi
désert aussi aride
allons bonne route que la mine
e
maintenant il faut s'installer le
matériel doit être sorti mon thé préparé
je
leur méthode de travail exclut la photo
toujours dans ce cas imparfaite m'ont
ils dit
il n'utilise pas non plus le papier
calque qui ne donnent pas les résultats
espérés mais une simple feuille de
papier cellophane sur laquelle ils font
un relevé des dessins que l'on trouve
dans les grottes
pour reproduire ce calque il faut un
support à vrai dire aucun support idéal
n'a encore été trouvé que ce soit israël
le papier ou la toile tous inter plus ou
moins et se détériore pendant le trajet
du retour
je suis pas recouvert d'un enduit et sur
cet enduit seront reproduits en creux et
en couleurs les dessins relevé dans
n'importe quelle position il faut savoir
travailler on fixe sur la pierre le
calque de cellophane avec du scotch
et pour reproduire on se sert d'un gros
stylo à encre de chine
nos artistes s'en tire avec de
nombreuses courbatures car il va sans
dire que c'est un travail épuisant temps
à cause de la chaleur que des positions
acrobatiques qu'ils sont parfois obligés
de tenir très longtemps
au fur et à mesure de son travail il
calque
repart la couleur
et voilà
mais alentours tout n'est pas toujours
calme parfois le désert se fâche
changeant l'aspect de la nature le vent
se lève alors on se cache et lorsque
l'on revient le sable a tout mangé le
sable à te cacher il faut fouiller
chercher trouver
c'est l'histoire de quatre hommes un
préhistorien joseph petit un dessinateur
robert guerra un cinéaste georges bourg
de long et louis carles
quant au chien il a parfaitement
supporté l'épreuve
le résultat de leurs expéditions mais
excellent puisqu'il repartent 28 de ce
mois et cette fois pour le monter vesti
à
c